hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show so today we're going to look at how
circadian clock defects caused disease
so in a previous video I introduced to
you the circadian rhythm and I talked
about the clock of health and the clock
of disease and I'll put the link to that
video in the description but in this
video we'll look at some specific
examples that showed the correlation of
the circadian clock to different
diseases so firstly we'll look at the
link to council and then we'll look at a
genetic condition referred to as fast so
before I jump straight in is important
to recap what the three main clocks are
so firstly we have the the Sun the
light-dark cycle that is one of the
clocks we live by secondly it's our
intrinsic circadian clock but lastly an
important for this video is the social
clock and how we often live our lives
while we are out late at night and this
is in conditions of artificial light in
which kind of antagonizes the other
clocks and this can be referred to as
social jetlag and so to be really crude
and to make this sound oversimplified we
can think that if these three clocks are
aligned with each other they are going
to be constructive in terms of their
interference I'm saying this is also
referred to as circadian consonants
however if these clocks are out of line
with each other they're out of sync
it can cause disease or that same with
so it's thought see and this will also
be referred to our circadian dissonance
and so in this video we'll look at a
couple of examples that try to
understand how and why this might be the
case so first up we'll look at the link
to cancer so there's a lot of
accumulating evidence now that shift
workers are more prone to cancer but why
would this be the case so let's quickly
recap about what the circadian rhythm
actually is so the circadian rhythm
includes cycles in behavior physiology
metabolism and selectivity that
fluctuates on around a 24-hour x go
hence the name circle DM being about
today so I guess the issue with shift
work is that it goes against what we
referred to as being the clock of health
that during different times of the day
different processes are occurring for
example the secretion of melatonin in
the evening that would permit sleep
whereas shift workers are active and
working during this time periods but
what effect could this happen the body
to contribute to increase in low rates
for cancer how could shift work be
having an impact so a key readout for a
healthy circadian clock is gene
expression patterns and so part of gene
expression patterns is governed by the
epigenetic state of the cell we touched
on this last time I'll put the link to
the description this video of how the
key clock factors the transcription
factors that actually regulate gene
expression and so this one study looks
at the epigenome of shift workers of
females in Denmark and what they saw was
that these shift workers had differences
in epigenetic marks and this Kundera
Express altered the expression levels of
certain genes so importantly they
noticed differences in the methylation a
form of epigenetic marks on cancer
related genes and whilst these are still
just correlations it is important
information to try and understand
because potentially we could use this
information to create or to try and
alter the disturbances that are caused
by shift work but what about shift what
that causes circadian dissonance
so while circadian rhythms are intrinsic
to a cell in multicellular organisms
like ourselves each tone is the kind of
coordinate with each other so this is
achieved by the so-called conductor of
the circadian rhythms and this is found
in the hypothalamus of the brain the
suprachiasmatic nucleus or the Sen and
so it's the presence of light in the
morning that starts the circadian rhythm
in the hypothalamus or the FCN and this
kind of kick starts the rhythm and helps
to coordinate all of the different
rhythms in the different tissues of the
body and so this light signal isn't
restricted to sun lights this is
indicative of blue lights that
stimulates this event and so artificial
lights can have a similar impact and
hence shift work by going against
the night time by having artificial
lights can kicks out the rhythm at the
wrong time of the day so that was a
brief intro into a link between
circadian rhythm disruption and cancer
now we'll look at a genetic condition
that is caused by having a defects in
the circadian clock so the example boy
look at is the familial advanced sleep
phase syndrome otherwise referred to as
fast so anything that is familial is an
event that kind of runs within a family
and in this case this is because of a
genetic mutation that can be inherited
down the generations and so also given
by the name fast is an advanced sleep
phase syndrome so what this means is
that the scathing rhythm is advancing
but at a faster rate than what it should
normally do so whilst the rhythm should
be around 24 hours people who have fasts
have a circadian rhythm that lasts
around 22 hours but how does this happen
and why is this the case so one of the
reasons that fasts is referred to as a
disease is due to the fact that whilst
they have an around 22 hour
rhythm everything else like the Sun set
and the daily cycle on earth is still 24
hours and so one of the key events as he
already mentioned is about sunlight
kick-starting the rhythm in the SCN
every day and so anything that kind of
hopes or and trends the cycle was
referred to as a site gaber and so
there's still events occurs even if
people who have fast but is going to
have the effects of course on some
circadian dissonance
so what controls the phase length of the
circadian rhythm so one of the key
mechanisms to control the length of the
cycle is the transcription translation
feedback loop which we looked at before
and to keep ratings and regulate in this
process our cryptochrome and periods and
it is the regulation of the synthesis
and degradation of these proteins that
helps to control and maintain the
24-hour rhythm however in fasts there is
a mutation that is commonly seen in the
power to gene and this mutation is a
Severine amino acid that causes it in
said code for a glycine amino acids and
the
this mutation results in a loss of a
phosphorylation sites and so
phosphorylation of the period protein is
important for regulating its degradation
so by losing this phosphorylation sites
the per protein is degraded in a shorter
time periods and this has the impacts of
advancing the circadian rhythm so
although the degradation of cryptochrome
remains the same the effects of the
phosphorylation change on the period
protein has the governing impact of
advancing the rates of the circadian
rhythm to around 22 hours so we have
literally scratched the surface on the
amount of literature there is on this
topic but if you do want to find out
more information let me know and I can
also make some more videos on it or you
can research it yourself there's just so
much information online about it but
hopefully this video is giving you an
introduction at least to what is out
there and how Akkadian clock defects can
cause disease